Đình kính khi mọi người sẽ hãy ủng đấy là công chủ hành tự lý xe.
Đừng đi, hôm nước ngoài về và chá liên ngoài thì đã tụi tôi sẽ.
Mình bao thì mình là phải trong 1 tâm thế là mình học mà bởi vì thực ra cái ngàn đầu tạo của chị là thì xương,
cho không phải là cái ngàn đầu tạo về dễ, với là khi nó cũng không phải là chứ mua của mình,
là mình khi mình đứa vào phải bởi một cái tâm thế rất là cổ thử rất là thêm tốn mà sẵn sàng để học của người.
Nhưng mà chị nghĩ là bị tích dị dụng trang quình là mình cái dự án mà nó hay hơn,
mình cũng có cái cơ hội để mua thịt, cái cái ngàn đầu tạo của mình.
Mà cái cơ có cái có gì hết rồi.
Con gái?
Con gái, bởi vì nhìn tỏ bận khàn theo, hấp dẫn,
bởi vì nó mặc dù bán chị cũng không nói ra nhưng mà thực ra thì nghĩ là trong 3 tâm chị,
bà chị muốn muốn chị là một cái con chá.
Mời có thể gắn vãe, được cái sự nghiệp này,
tại vì mà cũng mình như là bà sẽ giống cái sự nghiệp này là giữa vào cái sự nằm tính cái sự quyết đoán,
cái tính nằm của bà rất là mạnh.
Thế thì bây giờ là sự chuyện dào trong một người lỗ nghiệp phải là,
mà thay đo được nhiều, và phải bị làm nạo nữ nước, sẽ rất là tháng nạo nêm.
Bà chị có bà dù là dù mẹ tỏa thì phải đo lại ở có điều kiện với việc này nó nữ vào học.
Sình đang ở tính mà không nó không có mẹ tất cả những cái tính quyết mà rất càng.
Đó phải đúng, thì như thế này.
Đúng, đây thì nói với lại mà chị được đoạn đoạn như là một chính bình là như thế.
Vì bà nó là mình mọng quá, là không bủ quyết li,
bà cũng phải răng đêm.